est ce que le célibat est quelque chose
que vous avez souhaité être célibataire
c'est raté sa vie oui dans les années 60
en tout cas je trouve qu'il vaut mieux
se marier quoi l'homme et la femme
ils sont destinés à être à vivre
ensemble ne pas finir vieux garçon ou
vieille fille c'est éternel célibataire
mal vu en société on n'a pas était
michal la france a su faire preuve de
créativité pour en finir avec le célibat
en 1962 voici l'élection de miss
solitude si candidate libre comme l'air
et un public très masculin plus ouvert
avec plus de candidats au mariage ils y
allaient foire aux célibataires une
tradition rurale par excellence ici à
esparros dont les hautes pyrénées en
[Musique]
ça chante ça danse ça joue du regard et
sa espère trouver chaussure à son pied
j'ai une femme et m 80 et les foires jo
célibataire existe toujours aujourd'hui
et ce n'est pas un hasard
certaines revendiquaient à l'époque des
centaines de mariages est ce que vous
pensez que c'est sérieux
alors vous espérez trouver un mari
jusque dans les années 70 qui lie à une
injonction au mariage une pression
sociale encore plus marquée pour les
femmes c'est ce qui explique la
sociologue suzanne mature 1970 cette
génération est élevé en passant de la
solitude est une tare peu si on est seul
on n'est pas bien on a besoin d'être en
groupe en communauté ce qui fait si on
se retrouve dans une vie de femmes
seules par exemple on a presque un
sentiment de culpabilité
mai 68 redistribue les cartes et peu à
peu le fardeau du célibat sad le célibat
c'est même devenu un choix revendiqué
pour certains en octobre 2010
63% de célibataires se disait satisfait
d'être
[Musique]